Speaker 1: Let's go next to Bodie. Is it
pronounced Bodie from New Orleans or Bodhi?
Speaker 2: Yes. It's Bodi from
New Orleans. Thanks so much.
Just like from point break, Patrick Swayze.
Speaker 1: Yes, your discord is already blinking,
so we're kind of hanging by a thread here on
keeping you on. But what's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, thanks so much for taking
my call. I just recently watched some of an
interview from from the former party manager. And
I want to ask about I don't really trust that he
and his co-chair, the former Republican governor
from New Jersey. I don't think they have a mind
to bring it to the presidency. But they did talk
about focusing more on local election stuff like
city councilman, local city politics. So I wanted
to ask what you thought about not just support
party, but about bringing American politics
more to local politics instead of just party
affiliations like Democrat or Republican. They can
maybe make new parties or just voting for people
who are independents in that sense, 100%.
Speaker 1: On the local importance of local
elections. I have voted in different local
elections during my life, in different places
I've lived, which were nonpartizan elections.
People don't declare a party. They doesn't mean
they aren't Democrats or Republicans or whatever,
but they don't declare a party. And you actually
have to hopefully figure out what they're about.
I think that that's great. As far as the forward
party we reviewed earlier in the week, the
interview that Andrew Yang did on CNN with Jim
Acosta. It was really bad for Andrew Yang. It's
just like what are the positions of the forward
party? They're not saying them. And because it's
Democrats and Republicans and he says we're taking
the common sense consensus positions, but he
won't say what they are. It's not forward. Party
is not doing it for me. Focusing at the local
level and doing nonpartisan local elections.
I'm with you 100%.
Speaker 2:
I completely agree. I saw that. Exactly. That's
what I was talking about after the Jim Acosta
interview. I got the impression from to now.
Speaker 1: Let me ask you, because you you
you might know more about the forward
party than I do. Is there a position
they have outlined on any specific issue?
Speaker 2: I will say the so their motto seems
to be right now that they have three primary
components on policies. Right. So first is
representative ranked choice voting. That's their
biggest. Number two is I believe it's gun control
and some sort of common sense gun issue. And
they have taken a civic and civilian position
on the election saying that it wasn't stolen.
Speaker 1: Okay. It seems that it's not exactly
the most courageous thing to say. One of our
big pillars in the election wasn't stolen.
But okay. I mean, at least it's something.
Speaker 2: Right? I think the entire model
of just having these three ideas and just not
saying eight points at all is quite nebulous and
stuff. But thanks so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. My pleasure. There's
voting from New Orleans. Great to hear from
you. Glad to have the opportunity to chat
about that. Yeah, we spoke about it earlier
and it was it was all kind of a little weird.